jadynn defending jacob i am hooked
completely hooked but the first thing i
want to know is did you do it is it you
are you the killer I can't say nobody
knows
yeah I can't talk about it can't tell me
huh it's making me crazy that's good
good it's really great so you play Jacob
and it's a heavy role it's a heavy
character because you're trying to
figure out the depths of him
so what was it like playing him and how
can you describe Jacob I was so much fun
um he really is like a dream character
yeah and he's very challenging to play
just because I'm the only person who
knows his what's going on on inside and
even Morton the director didn't know
more mark who wrote it so it was really
interesting to play and basically he's a
kid who's accused of murder and but he
is a normal kid he goes to school and
you know he tells jokes and he loves his
parents and he lives a good life but his
world has turned upside down with this
with this trial so you know regardless
of whether he did it he's going through
a lot and going through a lot of pain
and so it was just a lot of fun finding
discovering who he is throughout the
shoot and kind of creating my own
background for him yeah does this series
stay true to the book yeah it definitely
has this same a lot of same elements in
the same tone and but I think a lot has
changed in the book actually it's very
much from the perspective of Andy barber
the dad so I think this explores the
other characters and then a nice way and
Jacob is actually very different I think
he's more dark and brooding in the in
the book and I think Marc and Morton we
wanted to kind of make him more relate
and normal essentially yeah your
character is definitely hard to read
that's good like it did my job that's
great um Chris Evans playing your dad
what was that like what's he like in
real life he's awesome this is our
technically it's our third project
together yeah so I can't get away from
him but no he's definitely it's really
awesome to see him play such a complex
character as well and it's just fun
watching him acting and being on set
with him and he just brings so much fun
to sit but um also brings so much depth
and seriousness to the role and and it's
it's it's really hard to film a movie
where it's sure you know it's about this
family unit and if you don't have
chemistry then the show doesn't work and
it was really easy to find that
chemistry between the three of us and I
think that's really special and hard to
come by so I'm glad that that was the
case yeah
the series is obviously a serious
subject matter but what is it like on
set do you guys have fun
no yeah I know it's so weird to think
about it we're dealing with this the
murder of a teenager but it was so much
fun and we're having a good time
obviously there are a lot of intense
scenes in this but the most I think the
most difficult scenes to shoot usually
in a film are the ones where you have to
act natural and have fun and laugh like
fake laughing that's the hardest thing
to do yeah but we really didn't have to
do that it was really came really
naturally for for us on set just having
fun and telling jokes and so I think it
was it was a great experience for sure
yeah so where is the story going so I
know at the beginning we're seeing that
Jacob is being accused of a crime of
murder
and his dad and his mom are worried
trying to figure out how to protect him
and how this is all going to unfold but
what can viewers expect because I feel
like this could be a rollercoaster ride
yeah it definitely is a rollercoaster
and really it's them dealing with this
trial and really asking the question of
how far would you go for the ones you
love and I think that's a I think that's
a question on a lot of people's minds
not on their mind but I think it's a lot
of a question that a lot of people don't
know the answer to
yeah but really these people would do
anything for their son and I think a lot
of people can relate to that yeah and I
think it's a really special thing and
you also see these very flawed and
real-life complex characters and you see
their journey and them growing and you
see this family fall apart and come
together and yeah it's definitely a
roller coaster it's hard to explain
without giving it away yeah because
there's a lot of twists and turns and
I'm waiting to because I love the show
so much it's so good oh my god um happy
belated birthday
thank you just turned 17 what did you do
what kind of things do you get into
nothing interesting when I'm not working
I do school and I had some people over
for dinner very simple I I need a very
normal life yeah yeah what's that like
for you balancing school and you know
filming a series like this yeah I do
online school um which is very flexible
for my schedule and it's a lot of work
honestly - I mean I'll be filming for
however many hours 10 hours a day and
then have to every time I have a break
it's not really a break I have to go
rush and do school and try to retain
that information while
acting and yeah so it's it's a lot to
balance but works out yeah
have you spoken to fin from it chapter
two at all do you know any T on stranger
things for I do not know no but I just
talked to him yesterday actually but now
no spoilers I'm sorry I can do what kind
of preparation was involved getting into
the character of Jacob um well first it
came with figuring out whether he did or
not yeah which was difficult to figure
out and then just thinking about I mean
the thing about this is it's not simple
it's not a simple thing of whether he
did it or he didn't do it
hmm both of those things come with such
you know how did how did it happen and
or like what is their reaction or what
is my reaction to it happening and yeah
so was just discovering it was just
really painting a picture in my mind and
creating this story which which is
really it's difficult but it's a lot of
fun yeah just I think you become I
became really close to Jacob in a way
and I really was able to understand him
and relate to him and you know I think
it's it was a lot of fun just
discovering who he was
yeah is it easier to formulate a
character that's based on a book well I
didn't read the book I I actually before
filming I started it I read a few pages
I really liked the first chapter and I
put it down as I cannot read this
because it's actually from the
perspective of of Annie Barbour of the
dad yeah and as an as an actor you know
want to know the other characters
perspective on you
and also the character is quite
different
yeah so I wanted to stay away from the
book and and do my own thing and work
with Morton and mark to to create this
character that is very complex but I
couldn't rely on that text I yeah I had
to come up with it well have you got a
chance to watch the series in full with
me no I've seen as much as you have as
force to episodes are you comfortable
watching yourself No
yeah what's that like for you terrible
yeah I love watching I love watching the
show just to appreciate everyone else's
work yeah but me I just don't like
watching me just pick out myself and I
think it's nice to watch myself just to
grow and understand what I did wrong
because I feel like I did a lot wrong
but oh yeah I can definitely appreciate
the show for what it is